jetzt rufe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 6a und 6b sowie
zusatzpunkt 12 beratung des sechzehnten
entwicklungspolitischen berichts der
bundesregierung sowie beratung der
anträge der fraktionen der afg mit den
titeln
strategiewechsel in der
entwicklungspolitik
entwicklungszusammenarbeit im deutschen
interesse und digital politisches
entwicklungsland deutschland fördern
statt block 10 geschäftsmodelle in
afrika für die aussprache ist eine dauer
von
67 minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und das wort
hat die bundesministerin svenja schulze
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
keines keines der 17 ziele für
nachhaltige entwicklung wird bis 2030
erreicht werden wenn wir in dem
bisherigen tempo weiter machen so steht
es im entwicklungspolitischen bericht
der bundesregierung vom letzten jahr
aber diese regierung hat nicht vor
weiter zu machen wie bisher
ich werde das tempo deutlich erhöht und
die agenda 20.30 und ihre 17 ziele sind
die richtschnur auch für die deutsche
entwicklungspolitik
ein nachhaltigkeitszielen möchte ich
hier heute in dieser debatte ganz
besonders hervorheben und das ist das
scp fünf das sind gleiche rechte und
gleiche chancen für die geschlechter
denn das ist ein wirklich essentielles
ziel für eine starke für eine residente
gesellschaft gleichzeitig ist das scb 5
ein schlüsselfaktor für die gesamte
nachhaltigkeit agenda die überwindung
von armut und hunger können wir
beispielsweise ohne eine echte
gleichstellung nicht erreichen ich werde
deshalb eine feministische
entwicklungspolitik vorantreiben
gemeinsam
was wir gemeinsam tun mit unseren
partnerinnen und partnern in den ländern
des globalen südens aber auch in den
strukturen der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
geschlechter ungleichheit das sind die
sekte ist das ergebnis diskriminierender
strukturen diskriminierender normen
diskriminierender rollenbilder und ich
bin fest davon überzeugt wer die
menschliche gesellschaft will der muss
die männliche überwinden
ist in einer kommunistischen
entwicklungspolitik ist die gleiche
politische wirtschaftliche und soziale
teilhabe aller menschen unabhängig von
ihrem geschlecht von
geschlechtsidentität von sexueller
orientierung und dafür braucht es
gleiche rechte mehr ressourcen und eine
bessere repräsentanz
die voraussetzung für eine echte
gleichstellung sind natürlich gleiche
rechte und ich werde mich dafür
einsetzen dass dem ist diskriminierende
gesetze aufgehoben werden und frauen und
mädchen in allen lebensbereichen
rechtlich gestärkt werden das müssen sie
leider auch aushalten von seiten der afd
ich will den politischen dialog zu
menschenrechtsfragen suchen und
zivilgesellschaftlicher organisationen
in unseren partnerländern fördern
eine feministische entwicklungspolitik
braucht aber auch angemessene ressourcen
sowohl bilateral als auch mutig
multilateral werde ich neue schwerpunkte
setzen und mehr für die gleichstellung
tun und um auch mehr für die
gleichstellung zu erreichen und das
dritte ist die repräsentanz von frauen
auf allen ebenen muss gestärkt werden
wir brauchen frauen am tisch egal ob es
um internationale verhandlungen neue
strategien oder die konzeption eines
neuen vorhabens geht mit mir wird es
keine entscheidung über frauen ohne
frauen gehen
dass die unsere entwicklungspolitik ist
die gleichstellung nicht nur weil es
gerecht ist sondern auch weil die
ergebnisse dann deutlich besser sind wir
nummer ein beispiel rausnehmen nämlich
die landwirtschaft für einen vielleicht
ein bereich in dem sie dies nicht
vermuten aber wenn frauen den gleichen
zugang zu land haben dann erhöht sich
die landwirtschaftliche produktion das
ziel ist natürlich insgesamt die
uneingeschränkte wahrnehmung der
menschenrechte für alle zum beispiel im
bereich der gesundheit das recht auf
gesundheitssicherheit und körperliche
unversehrtheit für frauen vor anderthalb
wochen war der internationale tag gegen
weibliche genitalverstümmelung
durch die korona pandemie sind herbe
rückschläge bei der bekämpfung dieser
schweren form geschlechts basierter
gewalt zu verzeichnen mindestens 200
millionen frauen weltweit müssen mit den
lebenslangen körperlichen und
psychischen folgen leben zwar sind in
zahlreichen ländern diese praktiken
verboten aber es fehlt noch immer an den
nötigen schutz und strafverfolgungs
mechanismen es fehlt an der
unterstützung für die betroffenen
mädchen und frauen das thema weibliche
genitalverstümmlung muss in die
präventionsarbeit gegen geschlechts
basierte gewalt unbedingt einbezogen
werden
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
gibt noch viel zu tun und wie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart wird mein
ministerium dafür einen umfassenden
gender aktionsplan unter beteiligung der
zivilgesellschaft
erarbeiten es geht mir nicht um warme
worte sondern um ganz konkret um die
bereitstellung von finanziellen mitteln
in kanada das schon seit vielen jahren
eine feministische außen und
entwicklungspolitik verfolgt fördern 92
prozent der öffentlichen
entwicklungsleistungen auch die
gleichstellung der geschlechter davon
sind wir in deutschland noch weit
entfernt aber ich werde alles dafür tun
um die hebel umzusetzen und dafür setze
ich auch auf ihre unterstützung vielen
dank
svenja schulze die bundesministerin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung mit dem
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung es ist er inzwischen
sechzehnter wir schauen mal kurz in die
lobby in die west lobby des deutschen
bundestages wo es nach wie vor eine sehr
ordentliche schlange gibt mit
abgeordneten die hier abstimmen den
hintergrund laufen ja zwei verfahren mit
wahlen zu
gremienmitgliedern für beispielsweise
das vertrauensgremium dass es vom per
hand abgestimmt werden aber vor allem
auch für das
gremium
für sondergremium sondern können wir zum
stabilisierungs mit
mechanismus gesetz ein kompliziertes
wort wir gehen zurück in die debatte in
der jetzt diskutiert wird unter anderem
über das stichwort feministische
entwicklungspolitik der
bundesentwicklungsminister riehen und
georg pieper ist am rednerpult aus der
unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
wichtig war der entwicklungspolitik ist
vor allem kontinuität es macht keinen
sinn wenn innerhalb von einer
legislaturperiode ein themenbereich
herausgegriffen massiv überhöht wird und
alles andere dann was in den vergangenen
jahren an ansätzen geliefert worden ist
nicht weiter verfolgt wird kontinuität
und vor allen dingen strukturiertes
vorgehen auf allen bereichen die die
entwicklungspolitik ausmacht ist das
geheimrezept einer erfolgreichen
verbesserung der lebensverhältnisse für
die menschen rund um den globus und wir
haben auch noch im vergangenen januar
januar 20 21 aus anlass des davoser
wirtschaftsforums ein redebeitrag
unserer ehemaligen bundeskanzlerin
wahrnehmen können der auf seite 2 des
berichts mit einem zitat wiedergegeben
worden ist und gerade in den kritischen
phasen von pandemien und krisen ist es
nicht angezeigt die tätigkeit zu
reduzieren oder auszusetzen sondern ganz
im gegenteil es muss wie es da so schön
steht zitat eine schippe draufgelegt
werden und das werden wir in zukunft tun
müssen aber verehrte frau ministerin wir
werden natürlich war schauen ob es ihnen
denn gelingt diesen furiosen aufwuchs
der letzten acht jahre von
6,3 millionen euro haushaltsvolumen auf
13,4 millionen euro einer fast
verdoppeln
umzusetzen oder ford zusätzliche wünsche
ihnen viel erfolg in den
haushaltsberatungen mit ihrem
finanzminister christian lindner der
immerhin einer partei angehört die in
der legislaturperiode 9 bis 13
eigentlich alles daran gesetzt hatte um
das bnz abzuschaffen viel erfolg und
viel vergnügen bei diesem unterfangen
wir werden sie an diese leistungen
messen
[Applaus]
ich will aber kurz referieren was in
diesem bericht zu recht ausgeführt
worden ist und wo die wesentlichen
punkte einer erfolgreichen
entwicklungspolitik liegen man hat sich
dem hunger dem dem ausbau der bildung
der bekämpfung der armut der ausrottung
der krankheiten der reduzierung der
müttersterblichkeit und natürlich auch
deren zurückdrängen der uns immer noch
belastenden krankheit hiv/aids gebiet
mit ja richtig der erfolg ist noch nicht
vollendet das ist allerdings bei dieser
enormen herausforderung auch mehr als
nachvollziehbar und es gibt leider immer
wieder rückschläge die 2014 etwa die
ebola
krise und auch jetzt die korona pandemie
aber es muss fortgesetzt werden und da
sind aus meiner sicht in den vergangenen
jahren vollkommen zu recht die richtigen
vier säulen aufgebaut worden um das dach
der entwicklungspolitik stützen zu
stützen stärken der eigenen initiative
durch bildung gleichberechtigung und
armutsbekämpfung
stärkung auch privater investitionen
denn unter die privatwirtschaft lässt
sich eine nachhaltige
wirtschaftsbelebung in
entwicklungsländern nicht realisieren
innovations- und technologietransfer
moderne möglichkeiten die die
digitalisierung sind unverzichtbarer
bestandteil in der entwicklungspolitik
und natürlich und nicht zuletzt den
aufbau von fairen handel denn
wirtschaftliche tätigkeit besteht
natürlich auch im austausch von
leistungen und dazu haben in der letzten
legislaturperiode das lieferketten
gesetz auf den weg gebracht mein kollege
wird dazu noch weiteres ausführen und
ein
grundlegend erfolg der soll nicht
unerwähnt bleiben an dieser stelle es
ist das 0,7 prozent ziel erreicht worden
lange jahre haben wir darauf
hingearbeitet in der letzten
legislaturperiode ist es gelungen also
versprochen und gehalten
die cdu hat verlässliche entwicklungs
politik gemacht man
kann nicht in der verbleibenden redezeit
sicherlich nicht die gesamten 388 seiten
referieren und vorstellen deshalb will
ich aufgrund meiner persönlichen
tätigkeit im rahmen der globalen
gesundheit gerne die aktuell aktualität
der entwicklungspolitik im rahmen der
kapo oder pandemie bekämpfung kurze
skizzieren das ist keine aufgabe die wir
in deutschland alleine leisten können
wir brauchen verlässliche und vor allen
dingen vernetzten partner und da haben
wir seit jahren auf die zusammenarbeit
und die unterstützung von jahr wie der
internationalen allianz den gf atm aber
vor allen dingen auch der wehr gesetzt
die koordinierend weltweit die pandemie
bekämpfung vorantreiben muss waits oder
jungen fdp waren partner die von der
bundesrepublik mit signifikanten mitteln
gestützt wurden und die auf diese art
und weise
zuverlässig weltweit und für alle
menschen auf diesem planeten leistungen
erbringen können und wir waren auch in
der lage
akute
ereignisse zu erwidern im
juni 2020 ist mit entdecken bzw dem
fortschreiten der korona pandemie sofort
ein weltweites kroner sofort programm
mit einem volumen von 4,7 milliarden
euro um gesteuert worden um dann die zur
verfügung stehenden mittel zielgenau
einzusetzen alleine
schaffen wir die aufgaben die es
weltweit gibt sicherlich nicht wir
brauchen partner wir brauchen uns
zusammenarbeit wir brauchen vernetzung
aber eins ist auf jeden fall klar und
das ist vielleicht
den einzigen satz den ich auf den antrag
der afg verschwenden will
entwicklungspolitik ist zukunftspolitik
und entwicklungspolitik ist frieden und
sicherheitspolitik und es ist unter
keinen umständen vertretbar da und
irgendeiner form einen strategiewechsel
eintreten zu lassen denn damit werden
die erfolge die ihnen den vergangenen
acht jahren unter gerd müller und angela
merkel erzielt worden sind zunichte
gemacht dann nützt es auch nichts einen
aktuellen titel der feministischen
entwicklungspolitik zu wählen sie
brauchen strukturierte politik bei der
alle menschen alle gruppen alle
kontinente gleichermaßen
berücksichtigung finden und nur so wird
es gelingen ein nächstes kapitel in
diesem erfolgs in dieser
erfolgsgeschichte zu schreiben
wir werden sie an den aussagen und an
den ankündigungen messen aber wir sind
durchaus schon skeptisch ob das nach
diesen ersten ansätzen überhaupt
gelingen wird herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
georg kippels war das aus der
unionsfraktion und ich bitte um
entschuldigung für den versprecher bei
seinem namen hat sich hin wohin
angekündigt habe an die stadt broker
wird die nächste rednerin sein
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen während
in der west lb weiterhin fröhlich
abgestimmt wird wie sie jetzt gleich
wieder sehen bei uns das wird auch noch
eine weile sogar andauern das geht mir
wie gesagt um das sondergremium zum
stabilisierungsmechanismusgesetz tanja
brugger
es gibt auch durchaus
lieferketten gesetzt aber wenn ich mich
recht
es war ja gerade aus dem kanzleramt aus
dem wirtschaftsministerium blockiert
worden weil es nicht unbedingt das
herzensprojekt der cdu und hier haben
viele in diesem haus große widerstände
auch mit der zivilgesellschaft mit den
kirchen und mit den unternehmen
überwunden das ist endlich kommt und der
nächste wichtige schritt ist dieses
lieferketten gesetz nun zu europäisieren
ihm dadurch mehr wirkkraft zu verleihen
und dafür zu sorgen dass
umweltzerstörung und
menschenrechtsverletzungen kein
geschäftsmodell der zukunft mehr sein
und hat einige tipps sie haben ja auch
recht ist es auch sicherlich ein
lichtblick dass die 0,7 prozent für
entwicklung am bruttonationaleinkommen
endlich erreicht worden sind nach 50
jahren aber auch hier sozusagen lohnt es
sich einmal genauer hinzuschauen denn
wenn wir uns anschauen was die alte
bundesregierung mit ihrer
mittelfristigen finanzplanung vorgelegt
hat dann ist es eine fallende linie und
es geht nicht darum die 0,7 prozent zu
sichern solange herr müller im amt ist
sondern in einer welt in der die krisen
zunehmend dass eine pandemie gibt die
klimakrise armut hunger und krieg wieder
zunehmen da braucht es ein mehr an
internationaler gerechtigkeit ein mehr
an solidarität und deshalb haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag
verankert dass wir mindestens diese 0,7
prozent in zukunft garantieren wollen
und dass wir auch bei der
klimafinanzierung drauflegen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
man diesen mehrere hundert seiten langen
bericht durchliest dann gewinnt man so
einen eindruck und den hätte ich in den
vergangenen jahren auch hier in unseren
debatten da war immer ein minister der
schöne bücher geschrieben hat tolle
termine in anderen ländern in den
wahlkreisen gemacht hat flammende
appelle hier gehalten hat und eine
bundesregierung mit sehr vielen ressorts
die sich nicht so sehr um die fragen von
globaler gerechtigkeit und
internationaler solidarität zu gekümmert
haben der nächste bericht dieser neuen
bundesregierung muss ein bericht der
gesamten bundesregierung werden denn in
einer hoch vernetzten welt hat alles was
wir tun oder und alles was wir nicht tun
immer wieder auch auswirkungen in
anderen kontinenten der welt und deshalb
ist globale gerechtigkeit sind die
nachhaltigkeitsziele der agenda 20.30
nicht die aufgabe eines ressorts sondern
natürlich für die ganze bundesregierung
und da bin ich mit dem was ich auch
ändern muss wir müssen mehr tun für
klimaschutz und klimagerechtigkeit
wir sehen doch das ist die
industriestaaten sind die den großteil
der emissionen verursachen und dass die
menschen im globalen süden sind die am
meisten unter den klimaschäden leiden
und wir müssen mehr tun indem wir bei
uns unsere emissionen reduzieren und
daran arbeiten in dieser bundesregierung
viele häuser gemeinsam zusammen und
nicht mehr gegeneinander
wir müssen aber auch mit entwicklungs
und klima partnerschaften gemeinsamen
gewinn für alle generieren und natürlich
auch mehr im bereich los und der match
frau bürger gestalten sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der fw fraktion
aber auch globale gesundheit müssen wir
stärken und da denke ich auch wirklich
der zivilgesellschaft die einerseits
natürlich immer wieder anerkennt dass
deutschland hier schon viel tut aber
andererseits auch sehr deutlich macht
dass wir mehr tun müssen für die globale
ins gerechtigkeit und frau ministerin
wir freuen uns natürlich sehr dass sie
hier so prominent eines unserer
herzensanliegen dass sich ja auch sehr
prominent im koalitionsvertrag wieder
findet angesprochen haben eine
feministische perspektiven in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und das ist
ja genau der gedanke der dahinter steht
eine politik für entwicklung für
nachhaltigkeit von der am ende alle
profitieren die gesamte gesellschaft wo
wir aber auch ein blick darauf haben das
ist gerade frau mädchen marginalisierte
gruppen sind für die von den krisen
anders oft auch stärker betroffen werden
das sehen wir auch in der pandemie sind
frauen und die sehr stark im
gesundheitssektor arbeiten es sind die
mädchen die vielleicht nicht wieder zur
schule gehen können wo der schulbetrieb
ausgesetzt worden sind und deshalb
freuen wir uns auf das kapitel zur
feministischen entwicklungspolitik im
neuen bericht der bundesregierung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
wünsche mir aber auch für diesen neuen
bericht eines dass er nicht ein bericht
wird wo sich eine bundesregierung selber
auf die schulter klopft sondern dass es
ein bericht wird denn der klare analyse
hat da auch eine ehrliche evaluation
freund dessen was wir vielleicht nicht
erreicht haben und warum wir das nicht
getan haben und dessen was besser werden
muss eine strategie für die zukunft fest
schreibt ein bericht der klar macht das
handeln der ganzen bundesregierung fühlt
sich verpflichtet der globalen
gerechtigkeit den nachhaltigkeitszielen
der vereinten nationen und der
internationalen solidarität vielen dank
dann herrscht darüber dass
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen in der
aussprache zum entwicklungspolitischen
bericht der bundesregierung und der
höheren jetzt die tma friedhof aus der
deflation die hfg hat zwei anträge
vorgelegt deren titel ich jeden
wenigstens vorlesen will
strategiewechsel in der
entwicklungspolitik der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit im deutschen
interesse ist der eine überschrieben und
der andere heißt digital politisches
entwicklungsland deutschland fördern
statt im block chain geschäftsmodelle in
afrika aber jetzt die immer friedhof
amerika und afrika schaut auf unser land
das ohne not gefahren wird vor die wand
wer vor wer fährt des vor die wand und
macht es krank er ist die alte nun auch
die neue regierungsbank mit deutschland
klappt es nicht so richtig deswegen
rettet auch die neue ministerin gleich
die ganze menschheit wichtig wagen wir
nach neun jahren minister müller
einblick in das illusionstheater der
gedruckten
entwicklungspolitischen erfolglos
geschichten und vorhang auf für die welt
der realität afrika ist fragiler und
zerrissener denn je krieger ausbeutung
hunger und armut wie nie das reichste
afrikanische land nigeria mit 200
millionen einwohnern hat eine geringere
wirtschaftsleistung als berlin und das
obwohl nigeria zu den rohstoffreichsten
ländern afrikas gehört die gesamte
wirtschaftsleistung afrikas ist die
geringer als die noch wir schaffts
leistung deutschland afrika benötigt die
unterstützung zur gestaltung eines
geschlossenen binnenmarktes aufbau von
wertschöpfungsketten im bereich der
rohstoff veredlung und für die umsetzung
der agenda 2063 die afrikanischen union
will deutschland will europa nicht
zwischen den machtblöcken der usa und
china zerrieben werden bietet sich der
afrikanische kontinent verein gemeinsam
partnerschaftliche wirtschaftsaufschwung
dazu an und der kontinent bietet nicht
nur chancen er hat vor allem viele
herausforderungen dabei müssen wir
endlich aufhören den kontinent zu
bevormunden der echte teilhabe will muss
mit dem eurozentristisch 'nen klima
feministischen quer geänderten
links-grün kultur kolonialismus endlich
auf verlieben
60 jahre entwicklungspolitik und kein
bisschen weise könnte man da ein wenig
mit
südafrikas eben auch durch eine falsch
verstandene hilfs politik korrupter denn
je der politische islam mit seinen
kampftruppen ist wieder erstarkt und die
bevölkerungsexplosion das größte problem
der entwicklungsländer
er zieht jeden gedachten erfolg gleich
wieder den boden so auch im bereich herr
doktor hoffmann im bereich der
weltwirtschaft solange die bäume afrikas
nicht nur in china sondern eben auch in
einem ungeheuren tempo unter den
kochtöpfen afrikas damit in der realität
bleiben bis zum jahr 2050 steigt die
bevölkerungszahl dna völkern 1,2
milliarden menschen sie steigt an um 1,2
milliarden menschen dass sie mehr
menschen als in den nordamerikanischen
staaten in europa und russland zusammen
leben sie kommen einfach dazu ich glaube
wer das nicht bedenkt hat wirklich
realität verlust aber wir haben einen
echten vorteil mit der neuen
bundesregierung die 70 oder 17
nachhaltigkeitsziele wollen ja dass die
lebensrealitäten der menschen sich
anpassen und liebe schwellenländer wenn
ihr noch etwas wartet kann ich euch
versprechen
wir sind bald bei euch angekommen
deutschland ist im bereich der
digitalität absolutes entwicklungsland
welt weit abgeschlagen und die neue
entwicklungs ministerin sieht gerade in
unserer digital kompetenz ungeheure
möglichkeiten und das ist kein scherz
die fähigkeiten unseres staates auf
katastrophen zu reagieren ist eine
absolute katastrophe
das aatal beweist einmal mehr
deutschland kann es sich vielen
bereichen nicht mehr das sehen wir uns
auch im bereich der deutsche
infrastruktur der energieversorgung der
bildung und gerade auch in unserem
veränderten demokratieverständnis
deutschland wird entwicklungsland gesamt
entwicklungspolitischen afghanistan mali
äthiopien und burkina faso mahnung
warnung und gerade auch anstoßen
umdenken sagt für eine residente
entwicklung welche frau ministerin
stoppen sie endlich das entwicklungs
illusionstheater und bmw den linken
ideologie betrieb und starten sie
endlich den normalen wirtschaftsteil
habe vernunft betrieb symbole der
menschen symbole der welt und vor allem
eins zum wohle deutschlands
der bundestag diskutiert über den
entwicklungspolitischen und berichte der
bundesregierung und dazu passt eine
meldung die gerade als eilmeldung über
die agenturen gegangen ist denn europäer
und kanada beenden den
anti-terror-einsatz in mali heißt es da
bei der deutschen presse-agentur
frankreich seine europäischen partner
und kanada beenden den militärischen
anti-terror-einsatz im westafrikanischen
mali man wolle in der sahelzone aber
weiterhin aktiv bleiben hintergrund ist
unter anderem dass die malische
regierung
militärregierung in nicht richtig
richtig kooperieren mit den kräften die
eigentlich den terror in mali beenden
sollten wir gehen wieder rein ins plenum
und zog notgeld aus der fdp-fraktion der
hier gerade seine erste rede hält
grafisch ansprechend die äußere hülle
ist dabei aber dass eine der inhalt das
andere der bericht benennt viele erfolge
aber er zeigt auch schwachstellen auf
wir freien demokraten haben klare
vorstellungen über die schwerpunkte der
entwicklung des politischen
zusammenarbeit in dieser
legislaturperiode vier aspekte möchte
ich darf denn die mir besonders wichtig
sind doch vorher möchte ich einen
grundsatz vorausschicken den ich durch
meine erfahrungen in der
entwicklungspolitik gelernt habe wenn
man menschen die chance und ihr leben
und ihr umfeld selbst in die hand zu
nehmen so ist das besser als jede
staatliche hilfe mit der gießkanne
multilateralismus eine internationale
zusammenarbeit ist nötiger denn je die
ersten ansätze zeigt der bericht auf in
manchen ländern setzt deutschland nicht
mehr
auf bilaterale kooperation sondern
beteiligt sich an multinationalen
strategien wir setzen auf starke
allianzen um entwicklungspolitik
effizienter zu machen erfolge lassen
sich so auch besser bewerten klima
politik für das klima gilt wie retten es
weltweit oder gar nicht dazu müssen wir
alles dransetzen um die nutzung
erneuerbarer energien in afrika und
lateinamerika
voranzubringen wir fordern aber auch
eine bessere globale verknüpfung der
vorschriften zum zertifikate handel mit
emissionen um die interessen der
entwicklungsländer
einzubringen gerade im klimabereich
sehe ich auch eine große chance für eine
beteiligung der privatwirtschaft diese
besitzt die mittel und das know how um
eine energiewende wende zu unterstützen
frauen und mädchen
das ist ein punkt den wir mehr in den
fokus rücken wollen die stärkung der
rechte von frauen und mädchen dies hat
nichts mit sendern zeitgeist zu tun
sondern mit einem plan blick auf die
fakten filmes wissen um familienplanung
mangelhafte gesundheitsvorsorge
eine noch nach wie vor hohe
müttersterblichkeit das sind die fakten
und wir werden die produktive und
sexuelle rechte von frauen fördern durch
informations offensive
durch dienste zur familienplanung durch
kontrazeptiva auch dazu ist ein
international abgestimmtes vorgehen
nötig dabei dürfen übrigens eins nicht
vergessen die männer mit auf diesem weg
mitzunehmen
beteiligung der privatwirtschaft es gilt
den teil wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
in der bezeichnung des ministeriums
klarer herauszustellen erste ansätze wie
der compact for africa haben bislang
noch nicht die geplante resonanz gehabt
es bestehen immer noch viele sorgen und
vorteile wenn es um investitionen in
afrika gehen sagen wir aber ehrlich
meine damen und herren alle mittel der
entwicklungspolitik aus deutschland ob
aus europa oder global können den
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt in
entwicklungsländern und schwellenländer
nicht allein voran bringen wir brauchen
dazu auch privatwirtschaftliches
engagement
sehr geehrte damen und herren ein
gedanke sollte immer dabei sein und
damit komme ich auch zum schluss
entwicklungspolitik soll unterstützen
soll helfen aber entwicklungspolitik
darf nicht auf dauer abhängig machen
manche länder und organisationen bemühen
sich sehr schnell an regelmäßige
zahlungen wir wollen einen wick lungs
politik bei der die länder immer
eigenverantwortlicher und
selbstbewusster die zukunft ihrer länder
in die hand nehmen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
im plenum wird weiter über den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung diskutiert themen der
west lori stehen die abgeordneten nach
wie vor schlange für abstimmungen
glieder neben der abgeordneten lobby
stattfinden wo es um das sondergremium
zum
stabilisierungsmechanismus gesetz geht
und wir blicken 6 zurück ins plenum da
ist nämlich schon am pult cornelia
möhring aus der linksfraktion sprecherin
für entwicklungspolitik die
kolleginnen und kollegen von ministerin
schulze auch die linke will deutlich
mehr tempo und eine feministische
entwicklungszusammenarbeit aber gerade
deshalb würden wir sie anders ausrichten
die interessen und bedürfnisse der
menschen denen unterstützen ländern in
den mittelpunkt orientiert an den
gedanken vor gerecht von gerechtigkeit
solidarität und nachhaltigkeit und stadt
in erster linie den
wirtschaftsinteressen der geberländer
und den konzern vorrang einzuräumen
würden wir eine globale umverteilung
einleiten um soziale ungleichheit zu
bekämpfen sie machen das leider nicht so
oder nicht konsequenten ein dramatisches
beispiel dafür ist afghanistan und die
zur verantwortung für die
zurückgelassenen arbeitskräfte liegen
auch bei ihrem ministerium die lage der
zivilbevölkerung wird immer
katastrophaler die wirtschaft des landes
ist weitgehend zusammengebrochen viele
haben ihren job verloren die meisten
menschen haben kaum noch geld und leiden
unter extremen hunger die übergriffe
gerade gegenüber frauen aktivisten sind
auf der tagesordnung und mittendrin im
elend und der zunehmenden gefahr
tausende zurückgelassene ehemalige
ortskräfte und ihre familien die nun um
ihr leben bangen und was macht das bmz
das bmz lehnt ausreiseanträge ab weil
die betroffenen nur einen honorarvertrag
hatten das ist unverantwortlich die
taliban man nehme keinerlei unterschiede
vorschüsse und arbeitsvertrag oder
honorar tätigkeit und da sie ja vorhin
frau kollegin broker hat erwähnt die
ganze bundesregierung sich zuständig
fühlt es braucht jetzt visa nach ankunft
und eine doppelte luftbrücke hilfsgüter
hin bedrohte zurück verhandeln sie die
aufnahme der direktflüge und sorgen sie
dafür dass humanitäre hilfe schnell bei
den betroffenen ankommt es ist schon
sehr enttäuschend wie behäbig die von
spd und grünen geführten ministerien
reagieren
das gilt auch für das thema im
gerechtigkeit während hier gepostet wird
was ihr gut ist waren im januar 22 05
prozent der menschen in ärmeren ländern
vollständig geimpft nur für elf prozent
hatten die erste impfung in einer
solchen situation wird der
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
zum umfaller des monats und ändert nach
einem gespräch mit der pharmaindustrie
seiner haltung zur patent aussetzung ich
finde das unglaublich
der schnelle ausbau von
produktionskapazitäten ist wichtig um
die verfügbarkeit zu erhöhen und zwar
nachhaltig auch um schnell auf
notwendige anpassungen an neue varianten
reagieren zu können in kapstadt gibt es
jetzt zwar fortschritte bei der
entwicklung eines eigenen impfstoffes
mit patent freigabe wäre das aber
deutlich schneller möglich gewesen und
ohne wird weiterhin wertvolle zeit
verloren nach presseberichten hat björn
czech sogar versucht die erforschung
eines afrikanischen impfstoff zu
verhindern angesichts des profits von
1000 dollar pro sekunde kein wunder ein
unternehmen bleibt eben ein unternehmen
und diese zeiten lieber konkurrenz aus
als sie neben sich zu dulden
aber genau das liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zeigt warum wir forschungen
pharmazie gesundheit nicht dem markt
überlassen dürfen darüber kann im
übrigen auch das gestrige werbe event in
marburg nicht hinwegtäuschen dass sich
ja so abfeiern unter dem deckmantel des
technologietransfers wird mit fabrik
containern die eigene produktion
ausgebaut das ganze dauert zudem viel zu
lange sollen nämlich mindestens zwei
jahre die pandemie liegt aber keine
pause ein anders als sie behaupten gibt
es mindestens 120 pharmafirmen globalen
süden die in deutlich kürzerer zeit die
produktion aufnehmen könnten wenn es
denn den technologietransfer gebe für
die logik des marktes gilt profite vor
gesundheit und deshalb muss die
gesundheit dem markt entzogen werden
geben sie endlich die patente frei
fordert cornelia möhring die sprecherin
für entwicklungspolitik in der fraktion
die linke im deutschen bundestag der
weiterhin über den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung in diskutiert und da
kommt jetzt rebecca scheinbar ans pult
aus der spd-fraktion auch sie wird jetzt
gleich ihre erste rede halten
[Applaus]
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesem jahr
werden
274 millionen menschen auf humanitäre
hilfe angewiesen sein
vergangenes jahr waren 84 millionen
menschen auf der flucht
45 millionen menschen droht eine
hungersnot
die lage ist dramatisch
wir dürfen uns an diesem zustand nicht
gewöhnen nicht abstumpfen sondern wir
müssen immer wieder genau hinsehen denn
über viele krisen wird kaum mehr
berichtet sie werden schlicht vergessen
was also tun angesichts dieses globalen
ausnahmezustands der sechzehnte
entwicklungspolitische bericht der
bundesregierung stellt richtigerweise
fest
entwicklungspolitik ist zukunfts und
friedenspolitik damit frieden aber
nachhaltig bestand hat braucht es in
zukunft eine bessere ressort
übergreifende zusammenarbeit und einen
systematischen ansatz der
krisenprävention
konfliktbewältigung und
friedensförderung
wir werden uns jetzt gemeinsam mit
unseren koalitionspartnerinnen und
partnern genau auf diesen weg begeben
mehr noch es wird einen grundlegenden
wandel in der entwicklungspolitik geben
im stil und in der sache wir werden
schluss machen mit ressort spezifischen
eitelkeiten da möchte ich mich an dieser
stelle bei den drei ministerin svenja
schulze annalena baerbock und christine
lambrecht bedanken die bereits sehr
deutlich gemacht haben dass
entwicklungs- außen und
verteidigungsministerium künftig mit
gemeinsamer stimme sprechen werden uns
geht es um kohärentes internationales
handeln und darum deutschlands rolle bei
der entschärfung internationaler krisen
weiter auszubauen
die leitlinien krisenprävention sind
hierfür eine hervorragende grundlage
wir werden den vernetzten ansatz weiter
stärken und mit leben füllen und die
ministerin hat es gesagt unsere
entwicklungspolitik wird für minister
sein mir ist bewusst dass sich der eine
oder andere hier im raum noch mit diesem
begriff anfreunden muss ich will ihnen
aber gerne erläutern warum eine
feministische entwicklungspolitik genau
der richtige schritt ist um auf frieden
zu fördern die zahlen sind eindeutig
wenn frauen an friedensverhandlungen
zwar von beginn an beteiligt sind steigt
die chance dass es erstens überhaupt zu
einem friedensvertrag kommt und zweitens
dass der frieden länger hält im sommer
deutlich zu machen handeln frauen
friedensabkommen mit aus steigt die
chance dass der frieden länger als zwei
jahre hält um 20 prozent
mit der resolution 13 25 aus dem jahre
2000 wurde das auch von den vereinten
nationen anerkannt zu dieser resolute
ziel dieser resolution ist es dass
frauen an friedensverhandlungen
beteiligt sind und so
geschlechterspezifische perspektiven
einbezogen werden über 20 jahre später
müssen wir feststellen dass
friedensverhandlungen immer noch
überwiegend von männern geführt werden
leider hat auch deutschland in der
vergangenheit nicht viel daran
mitgewirkt dass sich dieser zustand
ändert und genau deshalb braucht es
jetzt eine feministische
entwicklungspolitik weil es schlicht und
ergreifend sinn macht
es neu gewählte abgeordnete freue ich
mich daher dass wir wie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben und
besonders freut mich dass dieser wandel
auch auf der regierungsbank sichtbar ist
entwicklungs außen und
verteidigungsministerium in der hand von
drei kompetenten frauen
es geht aber nicht nur um mehr frauen in
verantwortung sondern darum das thema
gleichstellung stellung ins zentrum zu
stellen ungleiche machtstrukturen in den
blick zu nehmen und gemeinsam mit
unseren partnerinnen und partnern zu
verändern meine damen und herren die
globalen herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen sind immens die zahlen sind
schlicht nicht hinnehmbar
ich bin aber der festen überzeugung dass
wir einen entscheidenden beitrag dazu
leisten können ja sogar leisten müssen
diesen weltweiten krisen zu begegnen
jetzt ist die zeit für gemeinsames
handeln hier in deutschland in europa
aber vor allem auf augenhöhe mit unseren
partnerinnen und partnern im globalen
süden jetzt die zeit für eine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die sich eben
nicht als karitative sie versteht
sondern tatsächliche transformation also
einen grundlegenden wandel im sinne der
un
nachhaltigkeitsziele anstrebt herzlichen
dank
und das alles geredet und rebecca
scheinbar im deutschen bundestag hieß
mitglied der spd fraktion und hat noch
einmal betont warum feministische
entwicklungs und auch friedenspolitik
wichtig ist sind aus ihrer sicht
die den wahlgang von heute morgen auf
circa 11 uhr auf wunsch verschiedener
fraktionen so dass sie das in ihren
fraktionen noch einmal ihren kolleginnen
und kollegen mitteilen können um 11 uhr
schließen wir dann den wahlgang für die
geheime wahl jetzt hat das wort für die
cdu csu fraktion dr wolfgang steffel
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen
darf beginnen und auch meiner freude
dahingehend ausdruck verleihen dass wir
zu so prominenter zeit dieses wichtige
thema der wirtschaftlichen
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung
diskutieren denn internationale
zusammenarbeit und wirtschaftliche
kooperation mit entwicklungs und
schwellenländern hat nämlich sehr viel
mit respekt und partnerschaftlichem
handeln mit fragen der menschenwürde mit
fragen zum schutz des planeten und auch
mit friedenssicherung zu tun themen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
die uns als union wichtig sind themen
die auch minister müller und die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung in den
letzten jahren massiv voran gebracht
haben leider muss ich allerdings
feststellen dass wir hier jetzt von
kohärenten handeln und von der
wichtigkeit kollegen von den grünen von
der spd als angesprochen wie wichtig die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den ministerien
hier sei dann frage ich mich schon wo
ist die verteidigungsministerin wo ist
die aussenministerin die regierungsbank
ist hier nicht besetzt bzw nur mit
staatssekretären
anders meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren kann ich mir auch nicht erklären
und deswegen frage ich mich schon welche
wichtigkeit diese themen in dieser ampel
regierung spielen die gestrige
abstimmung im ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung dass dieser ausschuss ab
sofort auf den nachmittag verlegt wird
ein rund ausschuss wird was die
zeitliche behandlung von themen betrifft
denn für alle die die geschäftsordnung
nicht wissen nicht kennen wir können nur
noch themen behandelt wenn nichts
wichtigeres im plenum behandelt wird und
es wird dieser verantwortung nicht
gerecht meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren das heißt nämlich
es heißt nämlich dass die themen
menschenwürde respekt schutz des
planeten nur noch dann auf die
tagesordnung kommen wenn halt im plenum
nichts wichtigeres ist und dass meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wird vor
allem auch den moralischen ansprüchen
die ja insbesondere auch die fraktion
der grünen immer so gerne vor sich her
tragen nicht gerecht anders kann ich mir
das nämlich nicht erklären ich darf auch
nur erinnern an die debatten die wir in
der letzten periode hier geführt haben
zum thema transparenz und lobbyismus
aber jetzt hat es ihn ja neuerdings die
aktivisten auch ins haus ein offenbar
ist der neue leitsatz der grünen wir
reden nicht mit lobbyisten werbe ernten
sie in unseren häusern
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
gerd müller hat das thema der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung wie kein minister vor ihm in
die öffentlichkeit getragen und auch
hier ins parlament wir haben den
haushalt massiv erhöht unter der
regierungszeit von bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel verdreifacht und in den
acht jahren von gerd müller verdoppelt
zwar ministerin ich bin gespannt ob ihre
regierung ähnliches hinbekommt sollten
sie das schaffen haben sie meinen
respekt verdient ich bin gespannt die
haushaltswoche im märz wird wird es
zeigen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren der
bericht der bundesregierung macht eines
ganz klar wir als union sind unserer
verantwortung gerecht geworden in den
vergangenen jahren die zahl der
hungernden hat es sich bis zum einsetzen
der korona pandemie massiv reduziert die
gesundheitsversorgung wurde ausgebaut
die bildungsangebote wurden gestärkt
klima und umweltschutz ist gestärkt
worden übrigens von 2 auf mehr als fünf
milliarden euro und hier wird es auch
spannend sein frau ministerin ob sie
sich mit ihren beiden kollegen von den
grünen hier nicht gegenseitig auf den
füßen stehen werden der größere
klimaschützer ist besonders spannend ist
er aktuell auch die schlagzeile berbalk
fliegt linie ich kann nur eine sage ich
entspannen dass man darauf hinweisen
muss dass eine grüne ministerin linie
fliegt der hut müller ist meistens mini
geflogen übrigens in der vergangenheit
das war selten eine schlagzeile aber
offenbar wird es dem wähler klientel und
insbesondere dem grünen klientel gerecht
weil das wohl dort eher unüblich ist
linie zu fliegen sondern vielleicht eher
der privatjet genommen wird
meine
sehr geehrten
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
sind uns im ziel einig dass wir die
entwicklungsländer unterstützen müssen
dass wir diese stärken müssen dass wir
auch win win situationen haben und hier
gemeinsam profitieren können ich kann
ihnen nur sagen es wird mit staatlicher
unterstützung alleine nicht gehen und
frau ministerin sie
finden einen marshallplan den afrika vor
sie finden den wirtschafts investitions
vor vor vor hier sind große leitplanken
gesetzt worden der reformprozess bmz
20.30 es eingesetzt also ich kann sie
nur drauf nur auffordern bauen sie auf
diesem starken fundament von gerd müller
auf das haus ist gut bestellt es liegt
an ihnen etwas daraus zu machen vielen
dank von wolfgang stieler war das aus
der csu landesgruppe so aus der
unionsfraktion und weil er sich gefragt
hat wo die außenministerin und die
verteidigungsministerin denn sei da
können wir zumindest einem fall aus
helfen nämlich in der frage zur
bundesverteidigungsministerium die ist
beim nato verteidigungsminister treffen
in brüssel da wurden die beratungen
heute morgen um 9 uhr fortgesetzt und
die bekannten themen sind ja immer noch
dieselben jannik klaus giesen hohes ist
am pult für die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen gute entwicklungszusammenarbeit
zeichnet sich vor allem dadurch aus dass
sie sich konsequent an den echten
bedarfen der partnerländer aussicht das
problem ist in den vergangenen jahren
ist ein ganz ganz vielen stellen an den
echten bedarf von der partnerländer
vorbei gearbeitet worden und ihr bericht
zeigt übrigens auch der bericht der
vorgängerregierung die gründe dafür
punkt eins an ganz vielen stellen ist
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit für
nationale interessen instrumentalisiert
worden und punkt zwei da wo gute ansätze
da waren da sind sie ganz oft durch
wirtschaftliche lobbyinteressen
verbessert worden daran hatte die union
im großen anteil das ist keine global
gerechte politik das ist unglaubwürdig
und das werden wir beenden meine damen
und herren ich
will ihnen ich will ihnen ein paar
beispiele geben was wir dringend ändern
müssen und um an erster stelle direkt
mal mit einem mythos aufzuräumen es ist
eben nicht genug getan worden für
klimaschutz für biodiversitätsschutz die
bedarf es sind hier viel viel größer und
wir müssen hier mehr tun
anderes thema das hier auch sehr
ausgestellt haben die zusammenarbeit mit
der privatwirtschaft in der
entwicklungspolitik ich meine ich habe
das selber gearbeitet und ich kann sagen
dann gibt es auch gute einzelprojekte
das problem ist aber dass ein ganz ganz
vielen stellen viel zu sehr auf masse
und nicht auf qualität gesetzt worden
ist und so geht es nicht weiter
passend dazu auch das thema lieferketten
gesetz ist ja hier vorher auch schon mal
so ein bisschen ab gefeiert worden die
wahrheit ist doch dass am ende zu wenig
erreicht worden ist für umwelt und
menschenrechte übrigens auch weil
wirtschaftliche lobbyinteressen unter
anderem auch vorgetragen durch die union
dazu geführt haben dass dieses gesetz
verbessert worden ist was wir jetzt
brauchen weil das ja auf europäischer
ebene im moment verhandelt wird ist ein
wirksames lieferketten gesetz der eu für
menschen und umwelt weltweit das wäre
ein großer beitrag zu mehr globaler
gerechtigkeit
und ich will und ich will abschließend
noch ein ganz großes problem ansprechen
frau bereits vorhin auch schon
thematisiert das thema finanzen
ich finde es ist wirklich an
scheinheiligkeit nicht zu überbieten
wenn sie sich hier hinstellen und ihren
ehemaligen minister hier über den grünen
klee loben wenn die wahrheit doch ist
dass der haushalt des bmz nach ihrer
finanzplanung in den nächsten jahren
massiv zusammen geschrumpft werden soll
das ist keine seriöse politik das ist
scheinheilig meine damen und herren und
so geht's nicht weiter
die bukolischen gestalten sie
entschuldigung herr diesem buch
gestatten sie einen zwischen frage von
herrn steffen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
herr kollege finanz dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen während sie
bereits zur kenntnis zu nehmen dass die
letzte bundesregierung und der
unionsführung war mit einem
spd-finanzminister heutige bundeskanzler
der diese finanzplanung vorgelegt hat
würden sie außerdem zur kenntnis nehmen
dass sowohl die unions fraktion als auch
damals die spd-fraktion die
entwicklungspolitiker dort den
finanzminister für diesen vorgelegten
finanzplan
kritisiert haben würden sie außerdem zur
kenntnis nehmen dass die jetzige
entwicklungsministerin im kabinett
diesem plan zugestimmt hat und nur
entwicklungsminister müller eine
entsprechende protokoll notiz abgegeben
habe würden sie das bitte zur kenntnis
nehmen
sie haben das wort darauf dass steffen h
vielen dank für die frage ich will ihnen
damit in einem satz antworten wenn sie
mit dem finger auf diese bundesregierung
zeigen dann zeigen mindestens drei
finger auf sie zurück weil sie waren
beteiligt an der letzten bundesregierung
und sie waren verantwortlich sie haben
den zuständigen entwicklungsminister
dazu gestellt meine damen und herren wir
wollen das besser machen in zukunft hier
stellen die echten bedarf für der
partnerländer in den mittelpunkt klima
menschenrechte biodiversität
geschlechtergerechtigkeit bildung armut
orientierung oder kurz gesagt die global
nachhaltigkeitsziele der vereinten
nationen das ist unsere richtschnur
damit der nächste entwicklungspolitische
bricht besser ausfällt vielen dank
die unmik lasse diesen es war das aus
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
kurz vor ende seiner rede hat ja noch
eine frage in sotschi finger mehr oder
weniger beantwortet edgar new york ist
der nächste redner kommt aus der fdp
fraktion und hält jetzt hier auch seine
erste rede wie vorhin schon mal erwähnt
es gibt auch zwei anträge der afd zu
diesem tagesordnungspunkt
unternehmer in mitteldeutschland und
darf mich seit meiner direktwahlen mit
der deutschen entwicklungspolitik
auseinandersetzen das ist zugegeben noch
nicht allzu lange doch was ich hier
bisher beobachten konnte muss bei jedem
vernünftigen bürger grundsätzliche
fragen aufwerfen um was geht es heute
eigentlich
alles was wir hier bisher zum thema
entwicklungspolitik gehört haben ist mit
verlaub eine selbstbeweihräucherung der
alten und neuen bundesregierung
gewürzt mit irrsinnig weltfremden
globalisierung fantasien und linker
klima history meine verehrten damen und
herren es ist zeit sich ehrlich zu
machen die deutsche entwicklungspolitik
ist an sich selbst gescheitert
wäre sie so erfolgreich wie es im
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung im hooglands format
dargestellt wird so müsste sie doch nach
über 60 erfolgreich zehn jahren
überflüssig geworden sein aber genau das
gegenteil ist der fall die ausgaben für
entwicklungshilfe sind weltweit
kontinuierlich angestiegen allein
deutschland hat im jahr 20 20 fast
25 milliarden euro steuergelder dafür
ausgegeben was ist also das ergebnis
ihrer so erfolgreichen
politik man sich um in afghanistan in
mali oder burkina faso wurden die
millennium entwicklungsziele im jahr
2015 erreicht
wenn diese hoch gepriesenen 17
nachhaltigkeitsziele der agenda 20 30 zu
erreichen sein
und das gibt mittlerweile selbst die un
zu ich sage ihnen was das ergebnis ihrer
politik ist ergebnis ist ein
überbordender verwaltungsapparat
ergebnis ist eine stadt ist voll
finanzierte entwicklungshilfe industrie
mit sogenannter
zivilgesellschaft und linken endlos
ergebnis ihrer politik ist die
konsequente abwendung vom grundsatz der
hilfe zur selbsthilfe und damit vom kern
der christlichen soziallehre das
ergebnis ist also eine völlige
alleinstellung ihrer eigenen
weltanschauung ganz zur freude einer
dekadenten wohlstands generation den sie
das kleine nutzlose afrika abenteuer
bereitwillig bezahlen aber
bestes beispiel für diese weltanschauung
ist allein schon die überschrift des
berichtes eine welt unsere verantwortung
nein deutschland ist nicht für die welt
verantwortlich und die eine welt gibt es
ohnehin nicht deutschland ist in erster
linie für seinen eigenen bürger
verantwortlich so wie jeder andere staat
hätte es auf verzicht und seine bürger
ist ein gesetz und aktuelle
herausforderungen vor denen unser land
unsere bürger stehen ist es ratsam
wieder zu einer rationalen politik
zurückzukehren also zurück zu kehren zu
einer politik die ganz natürlich eigene
interessen verfolgt und ich möchte
betonen dass das verfolgen eigener
interessen eben nicht dem grundgedanken
der entwicklungspolitik widerspricht im
gegenteil eine zusammenarbeit im
gegenseitigen interesse ist näher an der
realität und verspricht mehr erfolg
willen sagen
der bundestag diskutiert über in dem
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung und währenddessen sagt
die kollegin die mir redaktionell zur
seite steht beziehungsweise sitzt das
ist der tag der eilmeldung und die will
ich ihnen auch nicht vorenthalten
russland so heißt es eben france press
russland kündigt die rückkehr von
panzereinheiten zu stützpunkten einen
schauen wir mal wie viel an diesem
rückzug dran ist am pult des christoph
hoffmann aus der fdp fraktion
ich empfehle erstmal an den sitzungen
des ausschusses für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit wirklich teilzunehmen
sich da einzubringen da können sie noch
fehlen
der entwicklungspolitische bericht zeigt
was entwicklungspolitik leisten kann
aber er zeigt auch wo die defizite
liegen und zwei dinge müssen sich
dringend ändern wir brauchen klare
linien klare ziele statt spontaneität
und mangelnder kohärenz und die
ministerin hat ja heute gerade ein
solches ziel vorgegeben und dafür bin
ich dankbar dass wir ein klares ziel
hier formuliert haben die groko hat er
ein agenda surfing betrieben alles was
gerade so modern war wurde durch geht
durch getrieben also wir hatten die
migrations krise wir haben die
klimakrise wir hatten die kogit krise da
gab es dann immer spontane initiativen
die hinterher auch sehr publikumswirksam
positioniert worden sind aber das ist
doch kein erfolg unter stetiger wenn sie
jetzt sagen dass die weltweiten erfolge
in der hungerbekämpfung auf einem csu
minister zurückgehen glaube ich das ist
schon ziemlich vermessen es war
letztendlich die globalisierung dieser
welt wo der reichtum insgesamt gestiegen
ist die dazu geführt hat dass es bessere
zustände in diesen ländern gibt
bei all diesen themen der
entwicklungspolitik ist es klar dass es
im zentrum und armutsbekämpfung geht es
ist diese elende teufelskreis von hunger
schafft konflikte und konflikte schaffen
hunger und den müssen wir beenden und
das können wir tun wenn sie es wirklich
wollen und hier auch alle mal zusammen
stehen und
deutschland kann das nicht alleine
schaffen deshalb sind die spontanen
bilateralen ansätze die herr müller so
geprägt hat nicht der richtige ansatz
sondern müssen uns mehr multilateral
vernetzen mehr zusammenstehen mit der eu
und den internationalen gebern dann
haben wir eine chance die situation
deutlich zu verbessern und
sie haben es gesehen in der rede der
ministerin wir als ampel werden das
silodenken beenden und kohärent handeln
und eben ziele verfolgen und nich
spontane projekt aktionen durchführen
und publikumswirksam feiern also um die
ministerin hat völlig recht zum beispiel
die frauenförderung ist eine wirkliche
waffe gegen den hunger in dieser welt
und damit ist sie eine waffe die
konflikte zu lösen herr hoffmann ich
starten sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fdp-fraktion
nein würde ich nicht gerne machen gut
dass leute was wir ändern müssen wir
müssen mehr strategisch denken und die
ez mittel so einsetzen dass sie zu
hebeln werden dass sie zu verstärken
werden und so privates kapital wirklich
mobilisiert werden können meine damen
und herren das ist wirklich entscheidend
zu glauben dass die öffentlichen mittel
in einer art und weise die welt
verändern werden das ist ein irrglaube
das wird nie und nimmer stattfinden
dafür sind die öffentlichen mittel
einfach viel zu gering egal wie groß
unser haushalt wird wir müssen schauen
dass die ezb zum hebel werden das wäre
instrumente installieren mit den ez
mitteln wo private mittel dann
entsprechend folgen
und die geopolitischen verschiebungen
auf dieser welt sind dieser tage ja
unglaublich spürbar und deutschland
braucht viele freunde auf der welt ja
sehr viele freunde auf dieser welt
und wir neigen eher dazu uns in fein
fest in politischen themen aufzuhalten
und denen den vorzug zu geben meine
damen und herren das ist falsch und das
ist nicht gut für unser land die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit wird oft
unterschätzt aber sie ist das zentrale
thema bei politischen stabilität bei der
klimafrage und der energiefrage hier
spielt die entwicklungszusammenarbeit
die entscheidende rolle und ich glaube
da verdient die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit mehr
aufmerksamkeit im deutschen bundestag
aber auch im bundeshaushalt und deshalb
werden wir dafür kämpfen dass die ziele
die im koalitionsvertrag verankert sind
auch so realisiert werden
herzlichen dank
christoph hoffmann war das aus der
fdp-fraktion und ihm wird jetzt folgen
als nächster redner manuel gasser aus
der spd-fraktion beide übrigens und für
die allermeisten redner in dieser
debatte mitglieder im ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung aber es gibt noch eine
kurzintervention des abgeordneten
frohnmeyer aus der afg fraktion
herr hoffmann ich muss das schon noch
mal einen haken gerade was die
wertschätzung
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch hier im
haus anbelangt wir haben das gestern als
ausschussmitglieder erlebt die fdp
fraktion hatte am anfang auch noch dafür
gestimmt dass wir vormittags unsere
sitzungen durchführen und gestern haben
wir erlebt und es muss ich mal sagen an
der stelle so fair muss man sein mit dem
ramsauer hätte es nicht gegeben dass
ganze
tagesordnungspunkte abgesetzt werden
mussten oder es zu verschiebungen von 20
bis 30 minuten kam weil er allen
überhaupt gar nicht anwesend sein konnte
das ist ihre wertschätzung für die
deutsche entwicklungszusammenarbeit hier
im hause das muss man an der stelle
glaube ich mal ganz klar sagen und dann
zum bericht und dann komme ich auch
gleich zum ende wir haben ja gar nichts
gehört heute wir haben wieder irgendwas
mit feministischer außenpolitik gehört
und solarzellen auf leben und dann
glauben sie sie wären die
lebensverhältnisse der menschen auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent
entschuldigung dass ein redebeitrag
sondern beziehen sie sich bitte auf die
rede von ihrem vorredner bei der
koalition darum mache ich auch sie
müssen mich einfach weiter sprechen
lassen dann würde ich das gleich tun
also herr hoffmann ich muss jetzt mal
fragen werden sich dafür einsetzen dass
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit wieder
den stellenwert hier im haus erhält den
sie verdient wird die fdp dafür sorgen
dass wir ganz normal wieder vormittags
tagen und die funktionsfähigkeit unseres
ausschusses hergestellt wird vielen dank
herr hofmann möchten sie antworten
das würde ich gerne
sie haben gesagt sie müssten jetzt hier
ein haken sie müssen nicht sie haben
gesagt die präsidentin müsste sie jetzt
weiter reden lassen das muss sie nicht
wir verkennen ihre rolle und das zweite
was ich gehen sagen will wenn sie hierzu
gehört hätten dann haben wir haben ich
genau skizziert was wir in der ampel in
der entwicklungspolitik gemeinsam
bewerkstelligen werden und sie halten
sich auf mit kleinteiligen geschichten
wie tagesordnungen oder sitzungstermin
vielen dank nächster redner für die spd
fraktion ist manuell gawer den ich auch
zu seiner ersten rede hier im hohen
hause begrüßen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen nach dieser
kurzintervention versuche ich jetzt
wieder zur sache zu kommen denn am ende
des tages geht es glaube ich nicht darum
wann die orga stattfindet sondern es
geht um den entwicklungspolitischen
bericht der bundesregierung darauf kommt
es an liebe kollegin
gerecht und nachhaltig wirtschaften das
ist die zentrale des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts die einbindung in globalen
lieferketten bietet gerade ländern aus
dem globalen süden große chancen für
ihre wirtschaftliche entwicklung jedoch
nur wenn diese integration nach fairen
und sozialen maßstäben gelingt
viele unternehmen verlagern ihre
produktion in entwicklungs und
schwellenländern und verfrachten somit
ihre anfallenden sozial und umweltkosten
dorthin dabei werden milliarden
erwirtschaftet und gleichzeitig menschen
und kinderrechte häufig missachtet
wenn wir weiter so wirtschaften wächst
die schere zwischen arm und reich
weltweit immer weiter auseinander dabei
haben wir uns mit der agenda 20.30 frau
ministerin schulze hat darauf
hingewiesen den nachhaltigkeitszielen
innerhalb der deutschen politik
verpflichtet
liebe kollegen kollegen selbst wenn wir
überteuerte produkte kaufen heißt es
noch lange nicht dass diese produkte
nach fairen arbeitsbedingungen
hergestellt werden produkte wie
beispielsweise kaffee aus brasilien t
aus indien oder wein aus südafrika
werden nicht selten unter missachtung
von menschen und kinderrechten
hergestellt ganz zu schweigen von
problemen der umweltzerstörung
liebe kollegen wir importieren kaffee
und kakao bohnen und exportieren soziale
ungerechtigkeit wir nehmen hungerlöhne
schlechte arbeitsbedingungen und die
ausbeutung von menschen jeden tag an der
supermarktkette in kauf und es ist jetzt
ganz wichtig und das ist mir besonders
wichtig dass es keine konsumentinnen
kritik denn das ist politisches handeln
was sie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber das gute ist dass viele menschen
uns dabei unterstützen denn bei vielen
bugs das interesse daran herauszufinden
wo das kaffeepulver innerhalb der
kaffeemaschine herkommt und die
nachfrage nach nachhaltigen fairen
hergestellten produkten nimmt weiter zu
und das erhöht nämlich auch automatisch
den druck auf die unternehmen die
verantwortung und bedingungen ihrer
lieferketten klar zu übernehmen und
darzustellen
gesetzgeberisches handeln ist
erforderlich und wir kommen als politik
nicht umhin faire bedingungen entlang
der gesamten lieferkette zu kämpfen
und wie alle glaube ich hier in diesem
hause sich eigentlich sind herrscht bei
uns in europa der konsens dass unsere
soziale marktwirtschaft zu standards der
menschenrechte der umweltfragen und
arbeitsbedingungen umfasst und genau aus
dieser überzeugung heraus haben wir als
bundesrepublik mit dem lieferketten
gesetz eine vorreiterrolle bei der
durchsetzung fairer und nachhaltiger
globaler lieferketten auf europäischer
ebene übernommen herzlichen dank an
dieser stelle auch an alle initiativen
energy aus an alle aus der
zivilgesellschaft die das ermöglicht
haben und auf ganz besonders an den
spd-geführten teil der letzten großen
koalition der sich durch große sache ich
mal schwierigkeiten und auch durch
großen kampf der union dagegen
durchsetzen musste und das hinbekommen
hat das land an dieser stelle
peinlich wäre ich von der afg das ist
immer ein gutes zeichen dass die rede
nicht ganz so schlecht sein kann wir
werden uns auch für einigen eu weite
regelung einsetzen wir unterstützen ein
wirksames eu lieferketten gesetzt dass
auch wenn menschenrechtsprinzipien
basiert und gleichzeitig kleinere und
mittlere unternehmen nicht überfordert
kollegen
[Applaus]
es macht ja spaß verbindliche regelung
im globalen den verkehr um
existenzsichernde löhne die rechte
arbeitsbedingungen und
umweltverträglichkeit sind das fundament
deutsche entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
wer dagegen verstößt verliert seinen
anspruch auf staatliche zuwendungen und
im extremfall auch seinen marktzugang
und das ist auch gut so
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren das
ziel ist die gesamte lieferkette
transparent rückverfolgbar sowie fair
und nachhaltig zu gestalten von der
produktion über den handel bis hin zum
verkauf um geschäft an dieser stelle
vielen dank dass ich meine erste rede in
diesem hohen haus halten durfte das ist
ziemlich imposant ich danke der
ministerin schulze dass das thema des
gerechten und nachhaltigen wirtschaftens
ein großer teil des
entwicklungspolitischen berichtes ist
und auf bessere zusammenarbeit vielen
dank
das war manuel gabe auch die
zwischenbemerkung wie er vorhin gemacht
hatte bevor er einen schluck wasser
getrunken hat war macht ja spaß und wenn
das nicht die zwischenbemerkungen des
tages ist dann weiß ich auch mit nicolas
zippelius ist der nächste redner in
dieser debatte in der es den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung geht aber auch um
entwicklungspolitik im allgemeinen und
besonderes und wie gerade im hintergrund
hören
bundestagspräsident in bars sagt auch
nicolas leoz hat hier seine erste rede
und er kommt aus der unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren die verwirklichung des
fairen handels zwischen industrie
schwellen und entwicklungsländern gehört
zu einer der vier säulen der deutschen
entwicklungspolitik fairer handel
ist hierbei das entscheidende stichwort
gemeinsam mit anderen staaten
entwicklungspolitischen partnern und der
wirtschaft wollen wir daran arbeiten
nachhaltige globale liefer und
wertschöpfungsketten verstärkt zu
verbessern
nachhaltigkeit und menschenrechte als
unabdingbare grundpfeiler des globalen
handels weiter zu verankern und somit
eine gerechte sowie nachhaltige
globalisierung weiter auf den weg zu
bringen
das wollen wir als cdu csu
dafür haben wir als union gemeinsam mit
dem ehemaligen bundesminister für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung gerd müller erfolgreich in
den vergangenen jahren die
entscheidenden weichen gestellt und
dafür werden wir uns auch in dieser
legislatur weiter stark machen
und die erfolge aus der vergangenen
legislaturperiode
die werden dem entwicklungspolitischen
bericht der bundesregierung sichtbar und
die können sich sehen lassen im juni
2021 wurde unter der alten
bundesregierung das lieferketten
sorgfaltspflichten gesetz beschlossen
die gewährleistung und sicherstellung
von menschenrechten von sozial- und
umweltstandards innerhalb der globalen
liefer und wertschöpfungsketten ist ein
anliegen anliegen für welches wir uns
als union auf eu ebene weiter stark
machen werden
und es bringt jetzt auch nichts liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der
ampelkoalition es so darzustellen als
wir uns hier einen völlig neuen
politischen grundsatz präsentieren das
bereits bestehende lieferketten
sorgfaltspflichten gesetzt ist eine
wichtige blaupause für eine europäische
richtlinie zu menschenrechtlichen
sorgfaltspflichten von unternehmen und
es zeigt dass die neue bundesregierung
auf eine richtungsweisende deutsche
entwicklungspolitik aufbauen kann und
dafür haben wir als union gesorgt
und das war nur ein beispiel der
geleisteten arbeit in den letzten jahren
das staatliche textil siegel grüner
knopf soll und wird nachhaltigen konsum
weiter prägen dann wurde ein zentrales
ziel der vereinten nationen zur
nachhaltigen entwicklung umgesetzt und
wie im entwicklungspolitischen bericht
der bundesregierung geschrieben hat sich
die zahl der teilnehmenden unternehmen
mit insgesamt 78 zeit programm
einführung vor fast zwei jahren ungefähr
verdreifacht und 100 weitere unternehmen
haben das siegel bereits beantragt und
das ist ein gutes zeichen und das ist
ein wichtiges zeichen meine damen und
herren
und nicht zu vergessen die gründung des
weltnaturerbes im jahr 2021 dieser form
wird bis zum jahr 2030 zur weltgrößten
naturschutzstiftung heranwachsen das bmz
unterstützt dabei 660 schutzgebiete mit
einer größe von zwei millionen
quadratkilometern beteiligt sich am
schutz von 130 millionen hektar wald
alles in allem zeigt der bericht frau
ministerin wo sie an die erfolgreiche
arbeit ihres vorgängers anknüpfen können
und auch anknüpfen sollten
und damit kommen wir zu ihren
hausaufgaben frau ministerin im
koalitionsvertrag herrscht leider
gähnende leere wenn es um das engagement
der wirtschaft in entwicklungsländern
geht und wenn es darum geht wie dieses
unter engagement unterstützt werden soll
und es ist daher von enormer bedeutung
dass das im eu projekt global gateway
von der bundesregierung nach kräften
protestiert wird bis zu 300 milliarden
euro sollen dabei von mitgliedstaaten
und institutionen mobilisiert werden
geld das hilft wichtige projekte der
privatwirtschaft in entwicklungsländern
abzusichern und wie wichtig die
unternehmerische ebene für
entwicklungspolitik ist hat doch gestern
erst wie das unternehmen bei und hat
gezeigt dass schlüsselfertige mobile
produktionsanlagen nach afrika bringen
möchte um vor ort
rm rm stoffe herstellen zu können und
wenn rot-grün unternehmerisches
engagement immer nur als teil des
problems sieht dann bitte ich dann
bitten wir doch wenigstens die
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp
dieses engagement als wichtigen teil der
lösung anzuerkennen
was die öffentliche entwicklungsausgaben
deutschlands betrifft haben sie
forschung zu ihrer letzten rede von
einem starken zeichen koalitionsvertrag
gesprochen das ist aber nicht mal
ansatzweise ihr verdienst ihr vorgänger
frau ministerin hat ihnen diese optimale
ausgangslage ermöglicht denn deutschland
hat bereits 2020 die internationale
messgröße von mindestens 0,7 prozent des
bruttonationaleinkommens für öffentliche
entwicklungsleistungen aufzuwenden
erreicht das jetzt zum beispiel die
grünen das kritisch kritisieren dass
nicht mehr dabei heraus kommen können
okay aber dass die spd dabei mit
klatschen das ist wirklich der größte
hohen und da kann man wirklich nur den
vorzügen von
vor minister wird das hätte übrigens
noch mehr werden können auch
mittelfristig wenn der damalige
finanzminister und ihr parteikollege
oder schulz eine erhöhung der ausgaben
keinen riegel vorgeschoben hätte und
sich mit fremden federn schmücken wenn
es passt aber ansonsten die schuld bei
anderen suchen das lassen wir ihnen mit
sicherheit nicht durchgehen lassen sie
sich das von uns gesagt sein
frau ministerin sie haben viel zu tun
wir als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
werden ihnen gerne ein kompass für
erfolgreiche politik im bereich der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung sein trauen sie sich
herzlichen dank
sagt nikolas busse der drittletzte
redner in dieser debatte war in richtung
svenja schulze und der abgeordnete pius
hat wiederholt und viele redner vor ihm
auch gerd müller angesprochen den
vorgänger von svenja schulze der ja mit
einem ganz haltigen ganzheitlichen und
einem nachhaltigen ansatz in der
entwicklungspolitik tatsächlich auch
viele neue wege gegangen die oftmals
auch die zustimmung von spd und grünen
durchaus hatten in deborah döring es die
nächste rednerin sprecherin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen
bericht hochgelobten reform war
entwicklungspolitik strategischer
effizienter und wirksamer einzusetzen
ob dies gelungen ist darüber lässt sich
ein anderer seite gerne mal diskutieren
auf jeden fall lässt sich aber
festhalten dass die strategische
komponente in müllers sinne umgesetzt
wurde leider denn entwicklungspolitik
stand in den letzten jahren immer mehr
im dienste von geopolitischen und
innenpolitischen interessen deutschlands
das sehen wir zum beispiel an der neuen
länder ist während neun sogenannte least
developed countries einfach raus
gestrichen wurden bleiben vor allem die
länder die auf der flucht und migrations
routen nach europa liegen als partner
vorhanden ungeachtet ihrer oftmals
autoritäre regierungsführung
menschenrechte kriterien oder bedürftig
keiten spielten in vielen fällen und
scheint eher eine untergeordnete rolle
das liebe kolleginnen kollegen
widerspricht nicht nur den eigenen
formulierten ansprüchen sondern ist das
gegenteil einer entwicklungspolitik die
effizient und wirksam für globale
gerechtigkeit kämpft
was passiert wenn deutsche
entwicklungspolitik probleme erzeugt die
es ohne sie nicht gäbe sieht man
beispielsweise im niger das bmz
unterstützt das land bei der ich zitiere
gestaltung einer kohärenten
migrationspolitik und lobt die schaffung
von kurzfristigen jobs als flucht
ursachenbekämpfung
wanderbewegungen im niger sind seit
jahrhunderten teil der
gesellschaftlichen normalität dort die
lokale wirtschaft lebt von
dienstleistungen für migrantinnen
2015 wurde dann die migration durch den
niger von der eu als problem
gebrandmarkt geld floss an die
regierungen um die migration zu
kontrollieren mit verheerenden folgen
für die migrantinnen und massiven
jobverlusten für die menschen vor ort
wenn wir fluchtursachen und nicht die
flüchtenden bekämpfen wollen dann müssen
wir anfangen die strukturellen ursachen
von armut und ungleichheit ranzugehen
und wir müssen endlich die bedürfnisse
die rechte und den schutz von
geflüchteten menschen voranstellen
ich bin sehr froh dass wir klar im
koalitionsvertrag formuliert haben
entwicklungszusammenarbeit darf nicht
davon abhängig gemacht werden ob ein
land in der migrations eindämmung
kooperiert stattdessen müssen wir
sichere und legale fluchtwege geschaffen
humanitäre visa ermöglichen und das
resettlement programm ausweiten und ich
freue mich darauf genau das in vier
jahren im weißbuch der
entwicklungspolitik lesen zu dürfen
gegen
90 die grünen da in dieser
legislaturperiode sprecherin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung und damit sind wir
logischerweise weil sie die vorletzte
rednerin war beim letzten mal die ja wie
komme aus der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren knapp ein
zehntel der bevölkerung auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent ist derzeit
vollständig gegen korona geimpft
das ist besorgniserregend denn diese
pandemie besiegen wir weltweit oder gar
nicht
die große koalition hat in der letzten
legislaturperiode bereits für
deutschland fortschritte erreicht um den
herausforderungen unserer zeit zu
begegnen
ich nehme hier nur drei beispiele
das bmz hat jährlich rund zwei
milliarden euro in
ernährungssicherung landwirtschaft und
ländliche entwicklung investiert seit 20
20 deutschland ein weltweites corona
sofortprogramm von sage und schreibe 4,7
milliarden euro um und über eine
milliarde euro werden jährlich
zusätzlich in globale gesundheit
investiert die bundesregierung ist der
zweitgrößte geber zu corona so kovats
initiative für die globale impfstoff
gerechtigkeit die gegründet wurde für
den aufbau der korona
impfstoffproduktion in afrika wo dann
rund 500 millionen euro investiert
der aufbau der lokalen in koproduktion
ist entscheidend um den globalen süden
unabhängiger von impfstoff importen zu
machen die bundesregierung unterstützt
deshalb vier afrikanischen ländern unter
anderem das institut pasteur in dakar im
senegal beim aufbau einer eigenen
produktion
das ist ein schritt um den afrikanischen
kontinent als souveränen qualifizierten
akteur wahrzunehmen in der aktuellen
pandemie hat sich seit was der kontinent
als effektive pandemie manager bewiesen
besonders
regionale zusammenarbeit und initiativen
der afrikanischen union
so wurden unter anderem
eigene seuchenschutzbehörde und eine
gemeinsame digitale
beschaffungsplattform für medizinische
ausrüstung gegründet dies zeigt den
kontinent als fähigen partner in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und das nimmt
uns in die verantwortung denn auch wir
müssen uns neu ausrichten hin zu einer
entwickeln zusammenarbeit auf augenhöhe
einer globalen strukturpolitik es war
eine sehr verdammt herren
aktuell wird uns die pandemie in der
erreichung der agenda 20.30 um den
nachhaltigkeitszielen denn es geschieht
enorm zurück wir sollten daher bis zeit
nach der pandemie nutzen um eigene f
neuen weg der nachhaltigen entwicklung
einzuschlagen die aktuellen
herausforderungen des klimawandels eine
globale pandemien können wir nur
gemeinsam bewältigen hier können ganz im
sinne der vernetzten ansatzes
investitionen in internationale
forschung hilfreich seien auch
die potenziale digitalisierung sollten
wir nutzen um beispielsweise den
universellen zugangs und
gesundheitsversorgung ermöglichen an
diesem punkt können wir von unseren
partnern auf dem afrikanischen kontinent
lernen fest steht die herausforderungen
des klimawandels
globaler pandemien können wir nur
gemeinsam bewältigen diese ziele der
agenda 20.30 müssen unsere richtschnur
für die entwicklungspolitik der
kommenden jahren sein packen wir das an
[Applaus]
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
und das bedeutete der
anträge die aus der fdp-fraktion hier
vorliegen als auch der bericht der
bundesregierung überwiesen werden also
im zuständigen ausschuss weiter
diskutiert und werden in den kommenden
wochen